police in the Bahamas say seven
Americans were killed in a helicopter
crash on July 4th the aircraft went down
about two miles from Grand Cay Island
killing everyone on board
they include billionaire coal tycoon and
philanthropist Chris Klein CTM lead
national correspondent David Begg know
is here with the very latest
Jericka good morning there were four
females and two other males on board now
Bahamian police have not yet told us the
identities of the victims the bodies we
understand have all been retrieved from
the ocean water they've been taken to
Grand Bahamas police and civilian
aviation authorities including those
from the u.s. investigate what went
wrong shortly after taking off from
Grand Cay Island this helicopter crashed
into the Atlantic Ocean it was heading
from one of the Bahamas northernmost
islands to Fort Lauderdale Florida on
the 4th of July authorities found the
helicopters submerged in 16 feet of
water after learning it did not arrive
at its destination former NTSB chairman
Mark Rosen Kirk says US officials will
work with Bahamian authorities to
determine what happened self-made
billionaire Chris Klein is among the
victims one of his daughters was
reportedly on the plane with him Klein
was a well-known philanthropist in his
native West Virginia
according to Forbes he joined the family
coal business at a young age and began
working in underground mines at just 15
years old he later developed some of the
most productive and economical coal
mines in the United States
Bloomberg called him the new king coal
on Thursday night West Virginia's
governor Jim Justice said on Twitter
that he lost a very close friend and
that Klein was always there to give what
a wonderful loving and giving man today
would have been Chris Klein's
62nd birthday you know something
interesting about the crash the chopper
took off around 2:00 a.m. but it wasn't
reported missing until police we're told
about it around 12 hours later
that's when it didn't show up in Fort
Lauderdale very horrifying just a little
detail about today would have been his
birthday that's that that always makes
it even worse to me when you hear that
they died actually on their birthday and
that no day's a good day to die but
that's always time that he was with his
daughter and we still don't know the
identities of the others all right David
thank you very much we'll see you again
tonight on the CBS Evening News